we're going back to comic-con 1,700
hours of building 4,000 hours hope it
works we are really excited about having
Stratasys on board they are one of the
world leaders in 3d printing technology
I've been at Stratasys for six years now
and I've seen lots of different sizes
lots of different geometries and
basically seen it all but this is one of
the biggest that we've had the
opportunity to be a part of 3d printing
used to be known as rapid prototyping
which is a way to take a digital model
is done in Maya's eBrush XSI Rhyno any
of those 3d modeling programs
it's like product development you don't
have to take it as a prototype and then
mold it and past it and go through that
on the process additive manufacturing is
your manufacturing Department you're
growing this realistic final part that
just looks at each individual slice and
it prints out one layer and then the bed
that it's sitting on is printing on
drops down and it prints another layer
that's why they call it growing so it
goes right from the bed of the machine
and has a little bit of sanding and
fishing and then paint it and it's done
materials are strong enough to withstand
the forces and the temperature and all
the other stuff is my key it is an
organic creature but a good percentage
of close to thirty five forty percent is
part surface 3d printable parts and so
what we need to talk about the parts
that were gonna send to stratasys to
grow so we want to send the arm all the
chess pieces the fingers as soon as
possible this is gonna be a lot of
modeling work so we're gonna have to get
this stuff going and out of here as fast
as possible
you only have such a size tray that part
that you can fit in the biggest machines
available it's about 35 inches by 24
inches by 35 inches that we have to play
for the size of apartment if we're gonna
use a program called materialized magics
to cut up the parts with keys to fit
them on smaller machines for machines
finish that are smaller we could put
those parts together and have a big part
that pretty much came up to nine hundred
so this is one of the samples that we
had gotten back from Stratasys I'm gonna
open this up and take some of this
coring out just as a test to see how
much lighter we can make it early on
when we were testing on finger digits we
were trying to see what other materials
out there higher grade than ABS that
might benefit this project as time went
on and resources started becoming news
we had a hone in pants on a material
that would just work in every area that
we needed to rent heat resistance just
being able to be beat up for this
project we chose to use our ABS m30
material which is our lower and
thermoplastic material and the reason
why we decided to use this material is
because it can be easily sanded so it
can be primed and painted we also chose
to use our 13000 spill there slice in
our forest production system and what
this allowed us to do was to turn the
parts around quite quickly I'm reading
by the phase email that we just came
from Michael block on the total number
of hours for our prints oh it is it
between 3500 and 4000 hours what holy
between 3,500 and 4,000 hours it's crazy
currently we have ten of our biggest
systems building these parts nationwide
our forest 900m see the nine hundred MC
is the biggest machine on the line that
can throw down ABS and other materials
at that size thirty-five inches by 24
inches by 35 inches that's what we need
we want to get as large single piece
volume parts out as quickly as possible
in a machine like that's going to handle
it forever
as soon as they came back we cleaned off
the support material and now they're go
to the model shop clean these things up
bond dose and prep they'll think about
attaching it in quarter sections for now
and then possibly seeing what
reinforcements set the seams were going
to do and things like that
I don't think 3d printing will ever
replace the human artists themselves
there's a lot that goes into the design
prior to the bill and there's a lot that
goes in after the bill so it's another
tool that the artist has as they create
cool masterpieces this was definitely
the biggest 3d printing project that I
in the studio has ever taken on before
and there's no question about it we're
taking on more and bigger next year when
we first started this project we had no
idea what we were getting ourselves into
originally had 15 hours of build time
but towards the end we were at 3,000
hours of bill time it really showed the
limits that we pushed ourselves being
able to make a project like this happen
so a lot of hard work a lot of team work
had gone into this to make this creature
come alive check out the wired channel
the scene calm for the entire giant
creature Sears
you